[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right hi everyone my name is Artur I
work on the Google security team as an
engineer and what my team does is we try
to make sure that we don't have security
vulnerabilities in our products and as
you might know Google has a lot of web
applications so Web Apps are a big part
of our world and the second major thing
that we do is we work with external
researchers that get paid for finding
vulnerabilities in our products when we
miss something so this puts us in a
position where we find a lot about new
patterns and new flaws that that can
affect the security of our web
applications and because many of our new
web apps are built using open source
frameworks such as angular and many
other ones we sort of learn about new
and interesting patterns that can affect
the security of possibly your web apps
as well fairly quickly right after we we
update code we very often get a new data
about some security flaws so my hope for
this talk is to is to share some of this
with you and I'm very helped I'm very
happy that Anand already hopefully
scared you a little bit when it comes to
security and the impact of cross-site
scripting bugs so my intent is to build
up on this a little bit and show you
some angular specific examples oh and
actually before I start can you guys
raise your hand if you know what angular
is or you if you've written any angular
code in the excellent ok this is music
to my ears all right so so let's get
started so know this is a security talk
but this is J's conf so I will not tell
you anything about like securing your
database or your back-end system so I'm
not going to talk about server security
at all we're going to talk about client
security and client security here is
making sure that the users of your web
applications don't get cannot get
compromised or attacked by evil websites
or networks right and science security
is a fairly broad area as well and you
know it's if you want to have a secure
website you should have HTTPS and
prevent a bunch of other things but
we're not going to talk about that in
general either
and I will focus on the biggest threat
that that sort of as an industry of web
application developers we've been facing
since web apps have existed and sort of
I know this is a subjective view but at
at least at Google this is something
that we are super concerned about so
cross-site scripting and also the other
thing is that for the other flaws the
other common things that we are worried
about in web applications we have a
relatively good way of preventing them
it might not be super straightforward
but if you want to prevent eavesdroppers
from listening on your users traffic and
getting access to your users data in
your web app then you know you can you
can deploy HTTP and HSTs and and you'll
be fine or I talked to a security
engineer they'll tell you what to do
it'll be OK for cross-site scripting
it's it's not really that simple there
is there are no panacea that will that
will really prevent your developers from
introducing cross-site scripting bugs
and if you've been here for an on stalk
and most of you have you already know
what cross-site scripting is so this is
just a super quick reminder if you
traditionally the way cross-site
scripting bugs got introduced is that if
you have an HTTP parameter that you
output to the to your page without any
escaping right so this on the top you
have a Python script you have a get
parameter you write it out and then what
an evil website can do is they can you
know point to that URL and make your
user execute an evil script one example
of an evil script was something that a
nun showed which is basically you can if
someone gave website gave webcam
permissions to your website they can
transparently enable it and sort of spy
on your users but it goes and much
beyond that actually so what's the evil
cult can do once it's injected into your
origin into your domain is it has full
access to everything your user can do in
the web application right and if you
think about sort of rich ecosystems of
applications such as you know any major
web
provider Google Facebook Twitter most of
your apps even the horsedrawingtycoon
app that Kurtis will talk about in in
the next session if you are in as an
attacker if you can inject evil code you
get access to to everything that a web
application has and you can also attack
other web applications that live in the
same domain as the application that that
has the cross-site scripting bugs and
the the last sort of thing that that we
worry about in general is that in many
cases you can persist your access to a
web application as an attacker after you
are able to exploit cross-site scripting
for a given user so what this means is
that even you know two months later
after even after the developer closes
the the cross-site scripting
vulnerability the attacker might still
be getting to be able to retain some
access to to the web app so that is
super scary so but you know the good
thing is that traditionally as
JavaScript developers we did not have to
worry too much about you know the
various ways in which you can introduce
exercise into your web apps because when
you purely write JavaScript code there
are there are only a few api's that that
might be able to the that could lead to
cross-site scripting right so things
like setting inner HTML document dot
write you know eval when you set URLs to
possibly JavaScript when you allow
setting JavaScript you are eyes for
example window open navigation and so on
so now if you know maybe five years ago
if you kept all of those in mind when
you are writing your JavaScript code you
would be safe from say 95% of the bugs
that that would otherwise get introduced
into your web app right just be careful
with all those api's but the thing that
is different these days is that we don't
really write web applications that use
those primitives directly right so it's
it's fairly rare I mean it's not like it
never happens but it's fairly rare for a
for a modern well-designed web
application
to use document.write for example I mean
there are special circumstances where
you might have to do that but it's not
that common and the reason why this is
the case is that there are many
frameworks and many new api's that were
introduced to make our lives easier as
part of these big web frameworks so that
we don't have to use those sort of bare
metal primitives like inner HTML or
document dot right and this is great it
really does make our lives easier but it
also makes it easier to use these API
without really understanding right
because if you have a framework that
wraps around one of these functions then
you know you are still vulnerable to to
the same class of issues but even though
you have not written code that uses the
dangerous API directly so one of the the
things that has been one of the
frameworks that has become fairly
popular recently has been angular and to
be honest I'm sure that almost all of
you know way more about angular than I
do
I am NOT an angular developer or
evangelist for that matter I'm a
security engineer and I know just enough
angular to try and break angular based
apps but not enough to build useful
things with angular but that's okay so
hopefully if you don't know too much
about angular I'll be able to show you
just the barest things that you need to
understand the code examples that we'll
talk about so yeah angular is pretty
popular so if just in case you you
forgot all about angular in the ten
minutes since I asked you if you know
angular this is how it works three short
steps you in the crew you include the
angular JavaScript somewhere on your
page then you write something that looks
like HTML sort of so you know you write
markup and you also have these ng
attributes that that allow your
application to do the angular magic
right you can have loops you can have
data bindings the mustache syntax which
will be pretty important in a few
minutes it's also something that is
it's not specific to angular but it's
one of those sort of big users of
moustache syntax so you write something
that that looks like a template looks
like HTML and the last thing is to
define your application and controller
and bind the JavaScript that you write
for your controller to the to the
appropriate Dom elements that has all
these bindings and this angular syntax
right so it's fairly straightforward
conceptually and this disallows really
powerful really cool web applications
may be built and you know there's a lot
of api's in addition to so the template
syntax is very rich you can do a lot
with that
there's components there's a lot of
api's for requesting data from the
server and you know really lots of cool
stuff you can look at examples it's
great all right so I've set it up a
little bit you know angular you know
this is a security talk so so what
what's the deal so when you start using
these frameworks there are a lot of
things that might look to be might seem
to be very safe but actually when you
when you sort of look more closely it
turns out there are subtle issues there
so and the first issue that we've
actually run into several times in
several of our applications is what
happens if you mix angular and
server-side template systems so I hope
that most of you when you generate
markup on the server are using a
template system because as Anant was
saying earlier this is something that
gives you contextual escaping so you
don't have to worry about manually
escaping every bit of data you know for
HTML or for javascript or for CSS
because you need different kinds of
escaping so the template system will
will take care of all of that for you
right so in the past you would have a
template you would render it and even if
you had evil inputs to your application
the template system would by default
just escape it properly for the context
at least if you're using a good template
systems the template system and most
most reasonable modern frameworks use
those and your
so okay so so what is the problem really
so this is what happens when you when
you use a template system on the
server-side and angular so the only
difference here is that we've included
some angular elements in our template
right we have the ng app and otherwise
we just render it all the same but what
happens is and this is in the bottom
code box is that the template system
will escape all your HTML meta
characters so you can't just inject HTML
but your server-side template system
knows nothing about the mustache syntax
that angular is using right so if you
allow this kind of output what it means
is that angular when it processes the
page after it loads it'll you know it'll
do its magic it'll try to find
directives in the angular controlled dom
element and it will execute them and
what this means is that as an attacker
you might not be able to inject
straight-up markup but you will be able
to inject angular use angular data
bindings execute arbitrary angular
controller functions so basically do
anything that that is defined in your
angular controllers and also the sort of
really big thing that that is not often
talked about is that it's possible to
escape out of the angular sandbox and
once you can inject the mustache syntax
into your angular app you can actually
you're very close to executing arbitrary
JavaScript and this is something that is
actually known right so if you go to the
angular security documentation page they
will tell you you should not make
server-side templates and client-side
templates because it can lead to those
sort of interesting interactions between
the two that will that will that can
possibly make your app vulnerable but
there are good reasons to do this right
like if you retrofit angular into
existing web applications which are
often generated in part with server-side
templates then you know you you will
have these issues
also if you want to pre-populate parts
of your page with data that the server
knows about and if you want to avoid a
call
for a callback to get this data you sort
of natural to do this so this is this is
one pattern that is sort of surprising
and interesting okay so let's say that
we know about this we we create our
angular part of the page statically
right we don't have any server-side
templating so we just have a very simple
application here which has just one
image and alt tag and you know it
displays a favicon okay so no so far so
good we have a controller the controller
has a dangerous function but we're not
executing it so you know everything is
fine nothing to worry about here so what
happens if before we run angular on the
page we insert and we run another
completely innocuous JavaScript function
so what this function is doing is it's
just finding all the image elements on
the page and it's adding an alt
attribute to every image you know this
is probably like a really crappy use of
the alt attribute that you should never
do this but you know we were just adding
some some data you know image from our
site and window location is something
that is controlled in part by the user
because you can open any web page with
location dot hash that the URL fragment
at the end so this is something that the
user controls but the alt tag when you
set it the alt attribute it's not a sink
right if normally if you do this nothing
bad will happen if you insert you know a
script tag or any HTML markup it will it
will not render it's just like a bit of
text but what happens here when this
interaction appears is before angular's
is invoked after our function runs we
will suddenly have this bit of Dom where
you have an alt attribute with data you
know so assuming that the attacker
injected a bit of angular markup in the
URL
suddenly what angular sees when it tries
to parse the page is an alt attribute
with the data binding and it will look
at it and I will think ok well now this
is something for me I would like to
and again as an attacker you are able to
inject arbitrary JavaScript and you know
and compromise the application so this
is this is another example of an
interaction where with before everything
would have been safe but because you're
using a client-side powerful framework
you start having problems all right so
let me give you another example so one
of the most powerful features of angular
and other similar frameworks are
includes where you don't have to have
all your HTML syntax in line but you can
include sort of sub templates and these
templates will be rendered as part of
your application so it's really great it
allows angular to fetch a little bit of
of markup anywhere from the server
render it in line and it's it's it's
super useful
so in here what we're doing is we have
this mg include that is based on the
template URL variable in scope of the
controller so when we set the template
URL variable we're just saying okay this
is just a path to an HTML file on our
server so no again nothing to worry
about it's fine the user language is
controlled by the user possibly but it
doesn't seem like there's anything super
wrong here right well hopefully by now
you know that all the examples are sort
of tricky so yes there is something
wrong and there's something bad that can
happen in this application so if the
user can control this variable part of
the URL from which angular loads the
template what they can do is they can
add you know and this is actually very
reminiscent of an old class of
server-side vulnerabilities where you
have directory traversal and you point
you are sometimes on the server able to
read files from different directories
than you would expect and here it's the
same but it's on the client so when you
know this sort of evil language variable
is is embedded as part of the include
value what will happen is that this this
URL is not is
longer pointing to you know a flash
angular slash templates slash something
it can point to a URL on your website
that redirects to to a completely
external site that might be controlled
by the user and because under the hood
what angular is doing is it issues an
XML HTTP request for data if the
attackers site replies with all the
cross origin headers the data that the
attacker supplies will now be included
as part of our application and that can
contain HTML in arbitrary scripts and
something that I should mention here is
that angular does have a mechanism that
will that by default prevents this from
happening but angular also considers
anything under your domain to be a
trusted resource and to angular this URL
slash angular search templates and then
dot dot slash this looks like a trusted
resource because it does point to your
web server and it has no easy way of
knowing that eventually after the
browser follows all the redirects this
can contain untrusted data so you know
by default if you if you use those kind
of patterns your application will be
vulnerable ok so another example so you
know let's say that just hypothetically
you have a horsedrawingtycoon
application and you use JSONP and that
completely hypothetical
horsedrawingtycoon application and so
the way it works and i'm sure most of
you are familiar with JSONP is you just
have json data wrapped in a callback I
have no idea why it's called Jason with
padding it doesn't look like padding to
me but that's that's what we've called
it for a few years so I guess the name
stuck all right so you know this is how
you use Jason P in anger there's a
convenience wrapper for for Jason P you
can just know call HTTP object dot Jason
P and what will happen under the hood is
the URL that you pass to to this
function will be used as a script source
right and if you think about what this
means
you would not manually ever write
JavaScript code that says you know
create a document create element script
and then as a source assigned evil calm
to it right but when you use the JSONP
api in a way that it's commonly used
which is especially for restful api you
say i want to load JSONP from from my
server you know slash api all these sort
of keywords that you expect and then
usually there is something that is
potentially controlled by the user so a
name of your object or an identifier of
your object and if you and if you create
a URL like this it's the same kind of
pattern that that we just saw with the
mg includes example basically if you if
as part of the URL you have dot dot
slashes what will end up happening is
that your application will fetch a
script from using an open redirector we
will fetch a scripts from an evil site
again now the evil application cannot
respond with HTML but it can respond
with an evil you know straight-up
JavaScript so you know maybe the JSONP
api is not that common but it what it is
what is really common in angular
applications is the HTTP GET api anytime
you want to retrieve something from your
server or any external resource use HTTP
GET and you know again the same pattern
if you just want to load say json data
right not JSONP but jason or any other
thing that you generate on the server
you you will have a very similar issue
and so so this is actually a very common
pattern that we see and by itself if you
just do HTTP GET on a potentially
external untrusted resource it's not
terrible because what will end up
happening is that you will issue an XML
HTTP request your application will get
the data but if it discards it or does
nothing with it you will be safe right
because the data just by calling HTTP
GET you're not doing anything that is
super scary but what usually have
is that the data that you that you
obtain from the server is used for
something later
right like generating parts of the page
so in here if we call innerhtml
we assign their HTML and use any of the
data that we've gotten from what we
think is our server but is actually an
attacker control response we will again
have a problem because inner HTML is a
Dom sink and then we have a bug but if
you you I'm sure you're thinking about
what I said before which is no one
really writes code that uses inner HTML
directly anymore so this is sort of a
fake example right yes it's a fake
example but what ends up happening much
more common in practice is that rather
than using inner HTML directly what you
end up doing is instead of instead of
using inner HTML you use some of the JQ
Lite wrappers that let you create part
of the Dom in JavaScript so JQ Lite is a
is a subset of jQuery that is API
compatible with jQuery so you just get
some of these convenience methods like
HTML append and a few others and in here
if you you know get data from the
attacker end up getting data from the
attacker and then you call append this
is sort of invisibly wraps around the
inner HTML Dom sink and you might have a
problem so in the past if I were a
security engineer reviewing the code of
a JavaScript application I would go grab
for an a inner HTML grab for a bunch of
these other patterns but in here we have
angular and any other framework like
that sort of injecting their own
wrappers that do the same thing but but
are sort of hard for both the security
engineer and the developer writing the
code to understand that you know they're
potentially dangerous and there's no
sort of big list that you can google and
sort of know that's that these function
calls are dangerous so you just sort of
have to keep that in mind
and sort of we're almost done I just
have a couple of things to to show you
that are maybe a little less used but
also interesting from the sort of sort
of new way of doing things perspective
so angular and other frameworks give you
direct access to some of the interesting
parsing functionality that the framework
has to do so rather than create a bit of
HTML sort of statically and then
invoking angular on it you can actually
create a string in JavaScript and then
call interpolate and it will an angular
will do the same thing as it would
normally do on your page so it will
substitute data bindings it will render
HTML same thing with compiling parts so
those are also things that if you pass
any untrusted data to any of those
functions if you manually need to call
them for some reason you will also have
another cross-site scripting bug and you
know the final example that I wanted to
to show you is something that Anant also
mentioned earlier and this is this is
probably the most common thing that that
is likely to happen in angular
applications in the past if you wanted
to render some HTML that that
potentially has JavaScript attributes or
things that might be dangerous in some
way but if your if you trust that you
control all the inputs you can say and
you bind the HTML unsafe and it'll be
fine
but this is a dangerous API because any
time you pass user control data to it
you will have a bug
now angular actually prevented this from
happening in new versions so now you
just have ng bind HTML which were which
will by default sanitize all the markup
that you give it so if you give it for
example a script it will just escape
everything but if you give it a bold tag
it will keep it because it knows it's
safe but there's a whole family of
functions that let you
trust bits of data as as HTML basically
tell angular okay this is fine don't
worry about it don't escape it I've
checked that it's correct and this tends
to be used improperly sort of as scary
as sort of with scurrying frequency all
right okay so what's like what's the
point of all this what I thought
initially as I was working on this talk
I thought okay I will try to scare you a
little bit and and then I will give you
solutions for all these things because
you know why wouldn't I I I don't want
to be a jerk right I want to tell you
how to write secure code but you know in
the end I decided I'll probably be a
little bit of a jerk and and not tell
you how to fix it and the reason is that
even if I told you how to address all
these patterns that that we saw on the
previous slides
it would not comprehensively cover like
all the sort of sharp edges of the
framework that you might need to be
concerned about so you would come out of
this room thinking okay I know
everything there is to know about
angular security I'll avoid these things
and it'll be fine but sort of in
practice it's not like that because
first of all angular is just one of many
frameworks and second of all there are
many other things in angular that we
don't yet know about the framework
changes so so instead of giving you
specific recipes or patterns for how to
avoid it I'll ask you to do three things
sort of to keep in mind that at a high
level first of all read the docs
I know as developers you know we often
want to just get things running there's
a lot of pressures but if you want to
have a secure application usually what
will really help is read the docs from
your framework and they will often tell
you you know what you have to keep in
mind or what you have to worry about the
second thing is talk to security people
you know either in person or on Twitter
and ask them you know I'm using an
angular what should I be worried about
because they you know we have security
fault get super excited about these sort
of minut trivia and details that lead to
these problems and you know actually if
you want to talk to me about this later
I'm super happy to do it because
no I love to do it so that's the second
thing and the third thing I wanted to
leave you with is I wanted to show you
that these kinds of things can be like
the sort of interactions between these
components and the ways in which you can
use new frameworks are are super cool
exciting and it's fun to think about it
and it's fun to break your own
applications next time you write code
like this think about whether it could
possibly be vulnerable to one of the
things I showed and overall this is just
super fun and I think it's almost as fun
as a horse drawing tycoon kind of game
and with this I'll leave it to Curtis
who has the next presentation about
something that I'm sure you will not
guess what it is
[Music]
[Applause]